one of the very best in the business
when it comes to chopping up this tape
and looking at these cut ups and
creating videos that we can see on
social media
is my good buddy brian baldinger from
nfl network and i could probably list
for
i don't know a solid 90 seconds all the
different gigs that he has but uh but
i'm not gonna
you can find him everywhere uh baldy
what's up dude
what's up dan good to hear your voice
man good to be with you buddy
you too brother uh i have been watching
some of your stuff leading up to the
draft on
nfl network and of course you got
podcasts and youtube and yeah odyssey
you're on radio shows all over the place
uh
what let me ask you this in terms of the
most polarizing player
in the draft at this point is is it fair
to say that's mac jones
yeah it is because um
you know it doesn't allow you with
athletic ability although you know we
have seen quarterbacks um
that have gone on and done great things
without that so
it's not paramount but i just think the
way the game is played right now
that you better be able to get a harm's
way when these coordinators
are sending you know these max blitzes
at you
and all we want to do is just get the
ball out of your hands as quickly as
possible
before you just get slaughtered so uh i
would say so i mean if he goes with the
third pick to san francisco
where i believe it's going to happen i
mean that fan base is
they're not you know they're going to
erupt there's going to be a backlash the
way
it was for donovan mcnabb in
philadelphia 1999 i believe
i think you're 100 right on sports talk
radio in the bay area
baldy all they're talking about is how
on earth can we trade two firsts
and a third round pick to move up to a
guy that looks like tom glavin with the
shirt off
hey by the way and the reason i use that
as an example baldi is because i was in
that old
braves locker room and you see smoltz
and glavine i remember being a young
reporter
and seeing those dudes in the locker
room with their shirt off i'm like those
guys look like my dad
i mean they're not athletic at all
they're hall of famers i mean
right if you can if you can spin it you
can spin it and
why does it matter what matt jones looks
like with the shirt off
who cares yeah i mean look the first
time i mean
first time i saw peyton manning in the
locker room i thought
who has the key to his sunken chest you
know i mean but
you know nobody's gonna argue with what
peyton manning did you know in the
in this you know in his career um so
it it it doesn't go hand in hand uh we
have all seen
uh players that you know uh that look
the part
and you know can't play so right that
really has nothing to do with it
uh the guy just went 13 games wired a
wire
like nobody would have ever seen i've
never seen anybody dan ever at any level
high school college pro complete 77 of
their passes
uh now you can say that it's alabama
it's an nfl roster all that stuff is
true
he's still through with anticipation
accuracy
um they still blitzed him he still made
the throws
he's got great mechanics so you know i i
trust
kyle shanahan to be able to locate the
right guy i just believed all along that
when he made the trade
back in march then he knew exactly who
he was going to get i i never believed
and i still believe that it was some
sort of competition
they just traded the three and they were
going to wait and see
which of the three that they really
liked i think he knew who he wanted to
get
no 100 percent and that 77
completion percentage is is astronomical
i mean
it's nobody's ever done that in college
football to your point but i will say
this
there are two others that have completed
over 75 percent of their passes
one is joe burrow and the other is colt
mccoy right so you kind of have a mixed
bag there in terms of what that
that means on the next level and the
other concern
you mentioned it he has four receivers
that will have gone in the top 15 picks
that's all said down i don't know
anybody's ever had that that kind of
talent to throw to so certainly that
makes guys look a little better baldy
but
if you're kyle and i'm the same way i
trust kyle i've known him for a long
time since he was in washington
there's nobody better in the business
when it comes to picking quarterbacks in
my mind
than than kyle shanahan but if you're
there based on what you've seen in the
tape study that you've looked at
are are you taking mac jones at three i
wouldn't
i mean i thought that justin fields is
the second best quarterback
in this draft and you know if you looked
at
ohio state against clemson semifinals
this year and i know you did
i mean justin fields outplayed trevor
lawrence i mean you can't get a better
game
than what justin fields did against
clemson uh but then you know people will
pick up
you know a northwestern game and where
he wasn't very good
but then i'll show you a nebraska game
where the ball hit the ground one time
the whole day
um i i just think justin fields is
supremely talented
and i just think that it's just the
beginning for any of these guys there
still has to be another step
and so the next step to me for justin
fields is just to do it on a very
consistent basis
but you're not going to find a more
talented player in this draft than
justin fields
so i i'm not arguing with kyle he can
put whoever he wants into his offense
and
he has that right you know john lynch
said it the other day it's up to kyle
it's his decision it should be his
decision
he's going to coach him every day but to
me justin fields
is the runaway uh player to be the
second best quarterback in this draft
so when we talk about best player in the
draft regardless of position the names
that
that continuously comes up is kyle pitts
i you know we may not have seen somebody
like this at the
tight end position uh who's as smooth as
he is i was watching one of your
breakdowns on twitter
he did this little pivot route yeah and
he created about 10 yards of separation
with a corner on on a pivot route it was
unbelievable
who is a comp if you can think of
anybody
from from the past or currently is
playing for for kyle pitts is there one
i mean you might have to go back to like
kyle winslow or
you know i mean just kellen winslow sure
you know back with
you know the chargers i mean player that
is a true flex tight end but can run
like nobody else's business right now i
mean he's travis kelsey but with you
know he's just
bigger faster um you know and more
athletic
uh then but that's who he reminds you of
and let's face it uh
most offenses that are really good right
now have some level of flex tight end
that they can just move around match up
i mean patrick sotan couldn't stay in
front of him jc horn couldn't stay in
front of him
in the sec uh he could either run by you
or
low post you or you know separate from
you on a pivot route like you described
i mean really there's no position that
you could put them in it's just really
up to the creative genius
of whatever coordinator you have right
now darren waller has become that guy
but even darren wilder can't run routes
and he was a wide receiver
coming out of georgia tech but even
darren wilder can't run routes right now
the way kyle pitts can yet he's you know
he's catching 100
passes right now in the nfl but that's
that's what kyle pitts is going to do
he's going to have a chance to catch 100
passes
or more every year and you know 10 12 15
touchdown passes because
you know 50 50 balls red zone jump balls
um balls on the top of the rim i mean
he's gonna win a lot of those
those uh match-ups right there so if
you're arthur smith
you're a first-time head coach you're in
atlanta
it's a football town do you do you go
with the best player
available at number four if it's kyle
pitts or
if you like justin fields and think he's
the second best quarterback in the draft
do you feel like you have to draft your
quarterback in the future there knowing
that matt ryan is going to play
a year at least maybe two for you
i've heard people say uh dan i know you
have two that you know
it's better to get your quarterback too
early than too late i just think when
you drop these guys right now
you know if if you to justin fields the
fourth pick i'm just
you know just for this argument uh
i think you just gotta start the clock
you just gotta start playing them
i don't know if there's a benefit to
just sitting
uh it did work out for patrick mahomes i
understand that uh it's rare but you
know
what if justin herbert sat all year last
year and didn't play and played behind
tarad taylor we
we wouldn't know what he became i just
think you got to play these guys but
look if i think arthur blank is going to
have
a lot to say about the pick uh i know
there's a new general manager in town
new head coach
but arthur smith once arthur blank wants
to put fans inside the mercedes-benz
dome
in atlanta if he thinks justin fields
can help him do that then
i think that might be a good smart pick
but if you believe that
matt ryan's got three good years left in
him right now dan
go get kyle pitts along with uh
you know with julio jones and and tommy
ridley and
hayden hurst and you know go put a
dynamic offense on the field
and go score 30 points a game and you
know fans will
show up on sundays in atlanta yeah
that's kind of where i am right now
baldy i just try to look at it
as if i were arthur smith and i'm trying
to win football games and the last thing
i want to do is
is you know start a rookie quarterback
and win five or six games my first year
that just that just scares the life out
of me because all of a sudden you're on
the clock
right as a head coach um all right so
i'm agreeing with you there michael
parsons best defensive player in this
draft is that no doubt dan helly by the
way talking to brian baldinger from uh
nfl network um and siriusxm and youtube
and sky sports
there's there's a long laundry list of
places you can find baldi is micah
parsons the best defensive player in
this draft baldy
you know if i thought dan that he was
going to be devin white
i'd say yes because he's got similar
talent to devon white
but i just don't think that micah
parsons especially after sitting out
this year
is devon white right now and devin white
changes the game
in tampa he did all year long
and he's the consummate pro he can do
anything he'd go out in the slot and
go cover devonte adams in green bay
i mean there's nothing he can't do i i
don't know that michael parsons
can do that i you know if you turn on
the cotton ball in his last
final collegiate game you think okay he
can but i i just don't see him hitting
the way devon white hits people and
impacts the game like that
so he has the talent to be that guy i
just
i'm not convinced he's devin white yet
i was going to save this question for uh
brian bilick who's coming up a little
bit later in the show
since he was in these draft rooms and
they're drafting guys but i i think i
can ask both of you because it's
going to be a huge issue in this draft
in terms of the players who did
sit out penne sewell sat out as well the
top offensive lineman
you got michael parsons who i think is
the best uh defensive player
or one of the top two or three in this
draft for sure um how much do you look
at that
as a general manager as a head coach if
there are
two guys on your draft board who are 100
equal and it's not a position of need
let's say but you're going to draft the
best player
one guy set out one guy didn't what do
you do uh
you know i don't know what the answer to
that is because i think it's just up to
the individual
and where you're at in the draft but i
know this dan
the nfl can only take what the college
game gives you
if michael parsons is the most talented
defensive player
in this draft then you're going to draft
his talent
it's unfortunate that he didn't play he
had a lot of players
rashaan slater there's a bunch of guys
that had that
chance to to play this year and they
opted not you know
ambry thomas from michigan i mean
there's a bunch of guys that
uh that did not play and i don't know
anybody that gets better by not playing
so uh and and you might go backwards
if you didn't play and you didn't
compete and you weren't on the field
you know seven eight nine 10 13 games
like they did
at alabama this year so i think it's
going to be a factor
in this draft dan yeah i think i i think
it's going to be a huge factor just
think about the guys there's two
quarterbacks right we don't have to look
back far right
zach wilson this year who wasn't on
anybody's draft board prior to the
season starting he was in a three-way
battle
to be the starting quarterback at byu
and then joe burrow who was a sixth or
seventh-round pick
and after a tremendous season he's the
number one overall pick right imagine if
they hadn't played
that year it so it i don't i think it's
i think it's fascinating you played in
the league for 11 or 12 years
is is it the type of thing where it
takes you half a season to
to get into game shape and remember what
you were doing or does it not take that
long
no look i mean i i think getting into
football shape
is a challenge for everybody now because
you know teams aren't going into their
facilities they're not working out you
know with their teams i mean they may be
going these
you know these exercise you know
facilities to go train
but it's not football movements um it's
not what you would be doing
uh you know at all these different
facilities right now so i think it's a
that's a question and a problem for a
lot of players i think it's
led to a great deal of injuries to start
players a year ago
i think we're gonna see a similar thing
this year dan i don't have the signs to
to back up that comment but that's what
i believe um and so i think it's a
factor and
if you haven't hit anybody since the
cotton bowl if you're micah parsons
you haven't hit anybody since the cotton
bowl against memphis um
i don't know how long it takes when you
you've been away from the game for over
18 months
before you start you know laying wood on
people
and you know getting your eyes back in
the right place and learning a defense
and learning the pro game and learning
formations and
you know pre-snap shifts and motions and
everything that you see at the nfl level
i mean it's completely different
so it may take some of these guys quite
a while to adjust it normally does
anyways
i want to get back to the quarterbacks
for a minute because you saying that you
feel like justin fields is the second
best player in the draft
seems to be uh against the consensus
right now zach wilson likely going to be
the jets
um uh number two overall pick what is it
about
fields that you like more than zach i
like the way he's built
i think he's more sturdy um you know
he's played through
injury we saw that against clemson last
year uh didn't miss a beat
i thought the fact that you know he came
out with this medical condition
you know last week dan and um you know i
he's over he's overcome that that's you
know anytime somebody would
say that you suffer from epilepsy that
be a roadblock that'd be an obstacle
and he's overcome that whether it's
through medication you know mental
toughness all that stuff
he's overcome that it hadn't you know it
hadn't knocked him down as a player he
started every game
um i i like the way that he can
uh just his arm strength
is just i think not that zach wilson
doesn't have it he's got an
electric arm you can see it in every
game i i just think zach will uh
justin fields just built better you know
i mean he's faster
he's bigger he's stronger he's shown
that he can just run through big ten
type tackles and
championship level game tackles um and
without any problem you know and i just
think that that's a factor in the nfl
when
guys you know a lot bigger stronger and
faster than you are going to hit you
so do you have zach as your number three
then yeah i had zach at number three all
along
um especially after you know watching a
bunch of games this year with them
uh he's got you know the problem dan is
with all these quarterbacks is patrick
mahomes
has ruined it for everybody yeah you
know because four years ago
who wasn't an analyst at our network you
know whether it was daniel jeremiah or
mike macdonald a guy out there
that said he needed mechanics he needed
work he's gotta
you know you can't play playground
football
and be successful and that's all he's
done and now all these guys want to
emulate them
and so now you look at those throws that
zach wilson can make you go oh
that's what patrick mahomes does every
week you know can he do that
you know the way mahomes has done it and
you know these guys the pro days are
trying to make mahomes types throws
that we see every week and he's kind of
ruined it for all these guys it's almost
like steph curry in basketball isn't it
everybody wants to emulate steph curry
now in terms of shooting the long ball
and now all these off platform throws
are
what we're enamored with is fans right
the no look stuff that's a great point
no but in fact i i don't even maybe you
remember better daniel
your memory's probably better but i
don't remember anybody saying
with quarterbacks off platform like i
don't remember that being a buzzword
the way it is now right and you know if
you want to separate
uh you know justin fields from let's say
a mac jones you know well
justin fields and zach wilson can make
off platform throws
that mac jones can't make and that'd be
a true statement
and so how much does that play into
anybody's decision to drop the
quarterback but mahomes
has made it commonplace this is how you
play the position now
um now you know he's he's had just
off-season toe surgery and he's come
back from a knee injury and
you know some of these all platform
throws kind of get you banged up as well
yeah no that's a good point they've uh
they've added that offensive line so
maybe he'll be protect a little bit more
he is uh brian baldinger uh the very
best in the business good buddy of mine
good buddy of the rich eisen show you
can find him at baldi nfl
on twitter baldy nfl on instagram if you
want to get a little insight
uh in terms of some film study always a
great place to go for baldy bald
anything you want to plug or pitch
before we let you go
uh well yeah look i just wanna nothing
about me i mean people can find me but
you know my favorite player in this
draft in is landon dickerson
and i know everybody knows about his
medical and the injuries all that stuff
but it's all a crap shoot like this guy
is
the best offensive lineman i have
watched since quentin nelson
wow and um that's who he is and so
somebody's going to take them and
they're going to keep their fingers
crossed and wear their lucky rabbit's
foot and all that stuff
and if he stays healthy he's going to
make your team better day one you know
what i am remiss baldy i had that on my
list to ask you about landon dickerson
uh an interior lineman from alabama
started his career at florida state
but had two or three injury plague
seasons and then really blossomed at
alabama so he's your favorite guy
i had to ask you about a lineman and i
forgot to so i'm glad you got that in
baldi
well i i'm i i have telepathy with you
dan i know you know
way back i finished your your sentences
many times over the years
so i figured i'd just finish your
thought there he's the travel dog brian
baldwin
hey baldy enjoy the uh enjoy the draft
great to catch up with you buddy i'll
talk to you soon
thanks dan appreciate you hey you
watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here